did you see this video
who hasn't seen the video tick tock
takes every single big thing like that
and rampages it through the internet oh
my gosh why is this slow like it was on
my for you page two minutes after it
happened make sure this is still going
okay i'm just making sure okay
will
smith
slap
okay let's let's do this
stop saying stop mouthing help me you
are fine you are absolutely fine stop
acting like
she's fine
that was a nice one okay
i'm out here oh richard
you want to get to the joke that he said
before he slept there
what you gotta get the clip with the
joke
okay well smith
joke
jada
i wanna
is this the full and it looks like it
okay this might be the full one you know
who's got the hardest job tonight
javier beldem and his wife are both
nominated
now if she loses he can't win
he is praying that will smith wins like
please
lord
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see it all right
[Applause]
okay so look at
i think he thought it was funny at first
do you see that yeah and then she is
like pissed off
because like these woke women they just
can't take a joke
like
okay if someone and i understand like
she's alopecia or whatever but if
someone i have seizures guys
if someone made a joke about strobe
lights with seizures like i'm not gonna
be a [ __ ] about it
i think it's funny still
like i get mocked at school for like
having the possibility of being like
because i have never had a seizure
before like we all know it's gonna
happen one day
like at this point it's just a comical
joke and he could have made a joke about
august that'd be way worse yeah you got
a joke about being bald
like that's it
anyway so look it she's she's not that
doesn't think it's funny he's laughing
[Music]
it's that one that was a nice one okay
i'm out here oh i'm guessing there was
some look where she like looked at will
and was like
you know
yeah and now
[Laughter]
oh wow
wow
oh my god will smith just smack the [ __ ]
out of me
all right do you think that it was
do you think it was fake because some
people are saying the slap was fake it
kind of just it doesn't look real but
also
like both of those people are actors
like it's very easy to just play off
but also it's very easy to recreate so
i don't know i think it was real
to be honest i think it was real
but
a lot of people in the manner of sphere
think it was fake
out your [ __ ] mouth
wow dude
yeah it was a g.i janeja keep my wife's
name out your [ __ ] mouth i'm going to
okay
he's also very unprofessional about it
what he was very unprofessional about it
like chris rock did a great job being
professional after it happened yeah
like like it's not like it we're at some
little little like this is the oscars
like
yeah like he could have
because some people are saying because
the ratings were low they thought of
this but i don't know i guess will is a
pretty good actor so
this very well could have been fake
but
i don't know i mean i see where she was
coming from
oh wow they do yeah they really show me
a picture of gi jane
a lot of people say it was staged it was
state i don't know
i don't i don't think it was staged but
i could be wrong
i i don't
i just think that the slap would have
been too far and i don't you're not
allowed to swear on tv
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television
okay okay
yeah i think he handled it very well and
he didn't even
okay i want to see will smith's
response speech
i haven't seen this one have you seen
this
what he said after he got no
um
okay this is
i know to do what we do
you got to be able to take
abuse you got to be able to have people
talk crazy about you why are you crying
as if in this business you got to be
able to have what would you say is he
crying as if we hit him
20 guys send super chats there's 110 of
you on here
come on like four dollars really
respectfully all the money is going
towards a new camera and new equipment
so
send super chats we'll read them i'm
gonna continue stop stop saying help me
stop it
people disrespecting you
and you got to smile and you gotta
pretend like that's okay
i want to apologize to the academy i
want to apologize to my all my fellow
nominees
um
so he won the award
that's going to be embarrassing
oh my god
this is a beautiful moment and i'm not
i'm not i'm not crying
for winning an award it's not it's not
about winning an award for me it's about
being able to shine light
on all of the people tim
and and trevor and zach
and sanaya and demi and anjanu and the
entire cast and crew of king richard and
venus and serena the entire williams
family
art imitates life i look like the crazy
father just like they said
i look like crazy father just like they
said about richard williams
but love will make you do crazy things
being able to love and care for my
mother my family my wife um i'm taking
up too much time
there you go hannah thank you
for
this
honor
thank you super chat for hold on this
moment and thank you on behalf of
richard and and orisian the entire
williams family um
thank you uh
hoping academy invites me back thank you
okay one
let's start
he's saying love makes you do crazy
things boy you're simping and thank you
for the 10 super chat and the 20dkk
super chat i appreciate it guys like
i want to do streams like this all the
time
um but i need to see that the demand is
there so when you guys send me money i'm
not even keeping it right now on april
1st everything is going to be going
towards a new camera and some new
equipment so all donations not even
keeping everything's going back into the
studio okay you could also send her
money to buy me a nice birthday gift
yeah her birthday's coming up too on the
forum
thanks for the remembering hannah um
okay okay okay um but thank you to
justin laughlin for ten dollars um jan
read this
road god made float i don't know but
okay so
and then jim bob says i thought gi jane
was a strong female character i
appreciate you guys um so
why is he saying that love is
like he's doing it out of love
like imagine imagine okay
if i
slapped someone over like the smallest
joke and i was like i did it out of love
you did this because you could not
control your emotions will
don't blame love on this one what do you
think
what are you
what do you think
no yeah definitely not out of love
take off the headphones
yeah
oh god
that's the last video we're watching
but
oh there you go okay
um no like why
this is like what happens though i think
when you you wife
girls that are for the streets
like none of this would have happened
but this is what i say like some
i'm gonna move the camera a little more
this way now because we don't need to
sit over there
because of the headphones like
some men literally prefer women
like they literally prefer women that
like disrespect them have you seen that
yeah
[Music]
yeah but the the difference with girls
though is like the traits that men find
attractive in men
it's like called the dark triad so like
for example like the same traits that
make someone a criminal make them a ceo
yeah i've heard about that actually i'm
saying but like men it's not like
they're supposed to be attracted to like
fit feminine friendly girls like that's
typically what they say but then you see
stuff like this where like a guy has all
the options in the world and he picks a
girl that's for the streets why
you could have had margot robbie my dude
like marvel like imagine having margot
robbie like who do you think's hotter
jada or marco
[Music]
she turns
actually i'm not telling them how old
she's turning okay i can send it in the
chat
like i just i don't get it because some
guys like
it's like they have so many options and
i found this where like if you're super
nice to a guy like they think it's like
weird almost like why are you being nice
to me
yeah it's like suspicious
have you
seen that because you're young like do
you see that with girls at your school
like guys like girls that are like
meaner sometimes
yeah i feel like i'm a nice girl and yet
here i am
they also just like the girls that are
like
oh that sounds wrong but like innocent
they like girls that are innocent yeah
but they're not actually like
i'm not gonna say her name because i
don't want to get like
right at the school but like
she's just the kind of person that like
you like you can't talk about about sex
around her because she's like
she's just so weird
it's like it's like guys like her is she
really pretty
no
really do you guys like her no yeah
really she's like the [ __ ] boy at the
school but she's like the kind girl
who's like i'm waiting till marriage
uh well her boyfriend's getting really
frustrated with it
well don't get me wrong like i do think
guys like like
the majority of guys do in my opinion
like nice girls and prefer like the
innocent like but there's a certain type
of guy i've just seen they prefer women
for the streets i don't know why
i don't know what it is
um let me read some of these super chats
um
okay the streets can someone answer the
phone we're calling
um sam men demessa
free pearls little sis that hashtag help
me stop saying that you it made you ten
dollars
you know what you can keep saying it
will has just created more problems for
himself now the internet is going to
fixate on their
problems more
two pounds
tanisha
merzoki thank you jacquis van
hout i'm sorry i'm so bad at names like
i'm so bad
um for the birthday 10 pounds thank you
and guys um at the end of the month i
need to make like
i'd say like 150-ish more dollars for um
for
the camera so i really do appreciate all
the super chats like you guys
you make you make this job worth doing
you stop telling them you're turning 18.
stop it stop it
um
why do you guys let me know in the chat
why do you think
okay so some people in the chat say that
they think will settle too young like he
got married too young and he should have
waited because he would have had better
options
i think yes but also that was just the
time
i just he was on the fresh prince of
bel-air though like guys like do you
really think that that was the only girl
he had available to him
being on tv back then
come on
i know he's like bigger and better today
and if he went out into the dating
market today like he would probably get
a hotter chick than he could have been
but
at some point like
men
choose these girls just like girls
choose toxic guys like there's certain
types of guys that in my opinion like
like to be controlled
um
two dollar super chat charles guitar i
guess i'm third place this episode
um skyler says the ginger sis is
a bagoo
is that your friend
this is his second marriage though
sex was good he that's his second
marriage was the first girl normal did
he leave her did she leave him
the sex was good so he fell in love he's
a simp look at this is what i say
certain guy girls guys can make a guy
fall in love like they're a hoes they
know their hoes they don't care
and they get really good at certain
skills in men i'm telling you fall in
love with these females i have seen it
i have seen it
i'm not saying they should but like it
just is what it is
but what do you think so what do you
think do you think he should have left
like early
when when do you think he should have
left her
or do you think it's right that he
stayed for the family
well his kids are older now so i feel
like at this point just go
i also think he may fear like i don't
think they have a prenup or anything
like that oh yeah i didn't even bring
that up
how much does will smith work 500
million i think something like that like
he's worth a lot
well oh
gosh
do you think at that point though it's
like even if they split half he's still
rich like stupid rich
beyond
like what are you going to do with 500
million that you couldn't do with 250
million